先生 はい  83行の一番上の行で
下の下に注釈の下に注がありまして
チャジャンティという言葉がワジャンティの代わりにチャジャンティという言葉が入る本もあると書いてあるんだけども
これサッパを 5分と取った場合ですね
チャジャンティっていうのは捨てるということですから
あまりそのチャジャンティということで取ることは良くないといいますか
あの表現には当たらないというふうに考えてもよろしいでしょうか
そんなのは私のカンカスじゃないですけど
まあチャジャティっていうのは捨てるっていうこともありますけど
歩くという意味でも使う場合があります
しかし チャラティっていうことは一般的に使ってるんだから
チャジェット捨てるっていうこと
まだ一般的でしょ だから誤解するでしょうね
そういうことでワジャンティでいいんじゃないかなと思ったんじゃないかなと思います
別にチャジャンティっていうことで悪いまずいわけじゃないんです
しかし あまりに珍しい意味を取らなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんですね
いや 分かりません それは私の管轄ではありません
この文法のそういうところはね
それはパーリ語の学者がやればよろしいし
ね ブラジャティというこのウダーナヴァーガにあるでしょ
サンスクリット語でブリジュという歩くというね
そのこれがプラークリットにパーリ語になっていくと
ブラジャティっていうのはワジャティになってきてね
だからそこでいいんだけど
だからそこでワジャンティっていうことはよろしいっていうことになってますね
知らない なんでチャジャンティ入ってるのかどうかは
ウダーナヴァーガだからね
すいません そしたらもう一度通して日本語の訳をちょっと言っていただきたいです
今日お話しされた訳をですね
通してその一句 あの句目からちょっと訳をお願いしたいんですが
どこからから？ サッバターのところからですね
もう一度全部訳をお願いします
だからサッバってウェーサップラサッバタっていうのは全てのところにね
ウェーっていうのは無しっていうことではある
歩いたとしてもってことで
サップラサワジャンティ仙人が行ったとしてもというぐらいの意味でしょうよね
至るところどこ 全てのところに仙人がもう歩いている
行っているとしても ナカーマカーマ欲は期待しないと
だから欲は期待しないと
私は好き嫌いはないということにしましたけど
ナカーマカーマで 1番目のカーマは欲
カーマっていうのは欲しがる
まぁ要求はないんだよと
だからこのカーマカーマっていうのはもう面白い単語で
カーマ 1番目のカーマは仏教でいう欲捨てるべきものであってね
次のカーマっていうのは
まぁ一般的な言葉で欲しがるという
これ欲ではないんです
カーマカーマの 1番目は欲で
2番目は普通の行為でね
ですから 1番目欲で  2番目はまぁ必要とするというぐらい
ラパジャンティっていうのはもう喋るっていうことですが
えーと まあそういうことですね
結局は 三宝を授いているんだから
あれが欲しいこれが欲しいということはないんですと
どこへ行っても それぐらい別に意味は簡単でしょうね
サキーナプッタアタワドゥキーナ
幸福に触れても 苦しみに触れても
ナウッチャーワチャン
上がったり下がったりすることはないんだ
あるいは動揺はないんだよと
だからうっちゃっていうのは舞い上がることで
幸福になったら舞い上がっちゃうし
苦しくなったらもう引っ込んじゃうしね
嫌な気分になるし だからこれはうっちゃー
うっちゃー 上がったり下がったりしないっていうこと
そういうことはパンディタ
ダッサヤンティ 賢者の心では見えてこないんですよ
はい  一切を知るっていうことについて
例えばすべての人のことをわかっていたりするっていうことではなくて
生命のことについて自分を見て知ることだと思ってたんですけれども
仏典なんかでは お釈迦様がその人の過去
過去生だとか その生まれ変わりだとか
そういうことをお話しになったというエピソードもいっぱいあるとして
つい一切一切を知るっていうことは
世の中のすべてのことについて
知識として 現象について知識として知っていることなんだって思ったんですけれども
お釈迦様のがちょっと特別なことお話になったっていうのは
それは神通力っていうことで
一切を知るっていうこととか
悟りっていうこととはまたある意味ちょっと別の話というところでしょうか
別だと思った方がいいと思いますね
お釈迦様の定義では 一切とは五蘊のことなんですね
過去 生命の過去は知っていることには
私は一切知ってるんだよって言ってない
あれは特別な能力で 過去の宿命なんかは明確に知ることはできますよというだけであって
その場合は一切知ってますよとは絶対使わないんです
それは現象で見るせっことだから
一切知るとは言わないんですね
一度も言ってないんです
一切智者であるというふうな場合は
一切っていうのは五蘊のことなんです
我は一切智者でありとお釈迦様を言う場合あるでしょうに
その場合は生命のことは過去現在未来であって
何でも知ってるんだぞという
ありえない話 そんなへんてこりんな話ではありません
すごい科学的な具体的な言葉で五蘊のことを知ってますよということは
生命のことは知ってますよということなんです
しかし 特別能力として自分の過去は色々知っているし
生命のことも過去は知ろうと思えば知ることはできたんで
それは特別な能力であってね
神通というふうに それは別にしているんです
いや 神通で過去を見ても
全て知ったっていうことはないんです
それはありえないんですね
もう過去を見たって もっとまた過去があるんだから
それはもうお釈迦様から帰っちゃそんなことじゃありえませんと
だからジャイナ教の教祖様も自分が一切智者であるということを表現していて
本人の定義は違いますね
本人が言うのは 寝ていても起きていても
歩いていても 立っていても
全て知ってる 本人が現象の世界でのことを知っていると言いたかったんですね
そこ 例え話もありまして
例えでわかりやすいんだから
例えばこのミラーボールがあるとしますね
で あの このディスコで使うあのミラーボールじゃなくて
あれは小さな小さなものを貼って作ってではなくて
丸いボールがあるとしましょう
ミラーボールは そうなってくると
もう全て映してるんですね
だから どこからでも入るものはもう何のことなく映っているんだと
それでニガンタナートジャイナ教祖様の心
魂が清らかになったんだから
もう知る機能は完成しているんですから
ミラーボールのごとく常に自然に映っているんだと
データが 情報というふうに説明までするんですね
そう お釈迦様が これはちょっとおかしいと
お釈迦様が科学的に これはね
ちょっとありえないんだと
すごい簡単になんであの人人に道を聞くんですかと
で だいたい旅に出る場合は
ジャイナのグループも仏教のグループもだいたい同じ方向へ一緒に旅に出るんですね
宗教違いだから別々なんですけど
何でもかんでも やっぱり何か分からないんだけど
一緒にいろんなところでお互い会ったりはする
だからお釈迦様も結構知っていて
もう何であの人はね 迷子になったり
また人に道を聞いたりもします
しますかねとかね その一言葉で現象では全て知るということはもう不可能
ありえない 冗談言うなよと
しかし お釈迦様は自分は一切知者であると言うんですね
それ一切知者っていうのは
もう五蘊のことはもう知り尽くしているんだから
いつでも何でも聞いてくださいと
生命のことなら 知らないものは何もないんだ
それは智慧であって概念ではないんですね
そういうことで この人数のところに来るのは
ジャイナ教祖様が言ったようなことなんですね
あれも知ってる これも知ってるというね
だからそこはもうお釈迦様の特別な能力で
そんなにもう  それで仏教が成り立っているわけじゃないんです
そういう超能力で 人相で仏教が成り立っているならば
もうもう知識的な理性の宗教でなくなっちゃうんですね
神秘主義になっちゃうんですね
ただ単に能力向上させしようと思えばいくらでもできますよということの証拠だけ
まあ心は煩悩があるんだから力がなくて能力がないんだよと
だから生きるということは心ですから
それはもう汚れたら困りますからね
汚れを落としてみなさい
落としちゃうと こんなこと
こんなこと こんなこともできるんだよというぐらいの話なんですね
そういうわけで 人数の話と一切の定義っていうのは別々なことです
はい えっと 智慧が出る前の人間がですね
理性で さっき先生理性で判断しなさい
理性っていうのは一体何なんですか
心の中で  まあデータを見てね
判断することですね  自分の体験ってこと
自分の体験もデータですね
やっぱり 例えば判断する場合は
なんとなく好みで判断したりするでしょ
理性じゃないんですね
これは自分の好みだとすぐわかるんだからね
あるいは 課長が怖いんだから
やっぱり良いことにしましょうとかね
課長の意見に賛成しましょうという場合も
やっぱりそれは本当にデータから判断したのか
課長が何か提案する 会社の上司がね
提案したら部下が あ じゃあはい
わかりました やりましょうと判断する場合は
ただ上司だから判断してたんで
あなた方は本当にそのことでいいと思いますか？という場合ね
別な話なんですね だから部下であっても
まあこういう状況だから
こういうこういうことだからね
こんなことしたらまずいではないかということを思っても言えない場合もありますね
だから この理性で判断するというと
誰にもそういう影響なく自分で判断するんですね
その時の気をつけようで
自分の感情が割り込まないようにというね
まあだから理性に達する前に
ちょっと論理的に物事を見るということをやっちゃうと
いくらか理性にはなっていくんですね
論理っていうのはちょっと危険なところもありますし
言葉の遊びになりますからね
論理は しかし 論理的にもの
それは誰でもやりやすいのです
論理はね 論理的に考えたりしてね
好き嫌いではなくて 論理的にという
で 持っていくと どんどん理性が生まれてくるんですね
いわゆるわかるように自分で考えるということなんです
最初から人間の中にあるものって考えちゃいけないんですね
あるもの  そんなのはないんだからね
何でも育てるものですよ
育てるもの  最初からあるって何もないんだからね
最初からもう猿と何の変わりもないでしょう
もうやっぱり教育を受けることによって我々は変わっていくんだからね
それも一つの無常のポイントなんですよ
もう変わります  理性も進化する
理性も進化するし 変わるっていう
理性がない人には理性育てることできます
普遍性がないんですね
いつでもという理性正しいという判断
理性がある人っていうのは一般的には少ないんです
少ない そんなにたくさんいません
完璧な理性  いえ 完璧でなくてもいいんです
別に 理性っていうのは基本的には少ないんです
人間はかなり臆病者なんです
で 西洋の方はもう理性で物事を言った人々はもう逮捕されたり
拷問されたり 殺されているまでしたんです
インド文化とはかなり違います
インド文化は理性はなかったんですけど
論理があったんですね
もう論争するんですね
だからいろんな意見あっていいんです
お互いもう論じていればいいんだからね
そこでこの論じる能力あったんだから
お釈迦様がそこから理性の世界を教えてあげたんです
だから論理が一つの踏み台みたいなものになります
例えば数学は純粋論理でしょ
だからって数学はすべて事実じゃないんです
頭の中で論理するだけで
もう実際世の中でそういうことはあるかというと
大体ないんですね 例えば私はこの神のことを非難するときは
批判するときはもう理屈使うんですよ
だから神は全知全能でありと
そちらはそう言ってるんですね
しかし 神が作った創造した人間が不完全ですね
罪を犯しちゃったんですね
神を裏切ったんですね
では 責任は誰にあるのかと
それで神を信じる人々は
人間が罪を犯したんですからと
私 論理的には自分の作品の欠陥は作品のせいだと言えるのかと
これは作者の問題ではないかと
だから人間は罪を犯したことは神の罪であると
その人は神であって人間ではありませんというふうに
これ論理なんですね そういう場合は論理で十分です
なぜならば 神がいるということは
何も証拠も何もないんだから
ただの人間の妄想概念でしょう
妄想概念はもう純粋に論理で潰しちゃえばいいのです
何か経験があって喋る場合はそことやり方は違うんですね
例えば瞑想している人々は
瞑想の経験でいろんなことを喋ったりするんですね
それは間違いは間違いで
その場合は純粋論理で論理でぶつからない
ぶつからないんですね
その時は理性を持ったり
もっともっと別な態度をとるのです
例えば瞑想すると 一番簡単にすごい単純に達せられる
達せられる経験というのは一体感なんですね
何か自分別にこちらでひとかたまりで瞑想しているということは
どんどん集中力が出ていると
なんとなく消えてしまって
消えてしまう 消えてしまっても
自分がちゃんと修行すること修行はしているんですね
何か自分がいるという気持ちが消えてしまったりして
それで何か何かこういうリミットが消えちゃうんですね
それでみんなこれこそ一体感やとかね
不二の経験 偉そうなことを言ってますけど
私は別にその経験は間違っているとは言わないんです
私はあのね 初めから一体でしたけど
そこはまずいんだから
修行しているではないかと
初めからも全て同じもので出来上がっているんだから
自分別な存在じゃないんだよと
だからそんな執着するなかれと
いうことで そこで純粋論理でぶつかるわけじゃなくて
理性 その場合理性使っちゃうんですね
まるっきりインチキな
このあり得もない妄想ばかり
精神的な病気で作っている神の概念
天国 永遠の天国などなどには苦労する必要ない
ちょこちょこした論理でいいんです
苦労する必要ないんです
では困ったな 考えておきましょうとかないんです
大体まず論理から始めると
理性がどんどん生まれてはいくんです
お釈迦様がこの理性説明する場合は単純にね
あの君たちが自分で考えなさいよと
で インド人に言ったんですよ
なぜならば インドではヴェーダ聖典にあるものは真実だと信仰していたんですね
だから聖典で聖典であるんだから事実ということはないんだよと
あるいは伝統だからとか
もうどうでもいいんだ
そんなのは 伝統はどうであろうとも
ヴェーダ聖典はどうであろうとも
それのその中で このプロバビリティー
もしかするとそうかもしれませんという
そういうプロバビリティーという可能性も捨てなさいよと
そういうことではなくて
自分で判断してくださいと
言って そこをやり方を教えてあげるんですね
では 私はここからこれから話しますよと
怒りは良いものですか？悪いものですか？どう思いますか？と
すると本人がまあやっぱり悪いものでしょうと
それで怒りでもって人が喋ったり
考えたり 行動したりする
その行為は善行為ですか？悪行為ですかと
それは悪行為になりますねとかね
では 悪行為には良い結果が出ると思いますか？悪い結果が出ると思いますか？と
まあそう やっぱり悪い結果でしょうと
お釈迦様 ほら あんた方でしょうに
答えたのは 悪行為するなかれと言ったのはあんた方でしょうと
だからお釈迦様は一応ガイドはするんですけど
判断するのは相手という
そこでちゃんと乗ってくる人は理性があるんですね
それで もうそんなこと言われたってよくわかりませんとか何とか言う人はもう当てにならないんですね
しかし 理屈の人はね 例えば怒りは良いことですか
悪いことですかと言ったら
うん 良い場合もあります
悪い場合もありますというかもしれませんね
では どんな時は良い場合でしょうかと
どんな時は悪い場合でしょうかと
はっきり言いなさいよというのお釈迦様は
だから理性も論理もなんか随分なんか似ているんですね
穴子とウナギみたいなもんです
なんか似ていて似ていないと
で もう一つ今思い出されたんですけど
あるバラモン人が 完璧な人っていうのは 5つの条件だよと
一 父親 母親 父親 母親  7代目までじゃなくて
一は体格が美しく 体が完全で美しいことで
それから父母までは純粋な血統でバラモン人であること
三はヴェーダ聖典を知り尽くしていること
四は道徳的であること
五は智慧があること 頭が良いことと
5つの条件 完璧な人の設計図をお釈迦様が教えたんですね
お釈迦様は違いますと言わなかったんです
なるほど では この 5つの条件で一つを削除するならば
あんたはどちらを削除するんですかと
いわゆる条件を 4つにするならばと言ったら
あ それだったらこの体がかっこいいってことなどどれでもいいんだよと
それは削除できますよと
お釈迦様はよくわかりました
あのね もう一度聞きますけど
この 4つの条件で一つ削除するならば
どちらでしょうかと言ったら
この 7代目まで父も母も
純粋なバラモン人で 血統は 그런ことがわかるわけじゃないしね
どうでもいいじゃないか
そんなのは だからそこを削除できますよ
なるほど わかりました
もう一度聞きますけど
あのね この 3つの条件の中で一つ削除するならば
完璧な人間である あるんだけある条件なんですよ
5つ条件必要でしたけど
やっぱりもう 2つ削除しちゃったんです
もう一つ削除できますかと
それでも完璧な人間である
ただバラモンには それならこのヴェーダ聖典丸暗記してって
そんなことなくてもいいんじゃないですかと
三聖典を丸暗記して解説できる
そんなことはまあできる人もできない人もいるんですし
あれ削除できますよと
わかりましたと では この 2つあります
戒律 道徳的であることと智慧があること
その 2つでは一つ削除できますかと
ただバラモン人はあのね
これは削除できませんよ
道徳ない人には知恵があるわけじゃないんだと
知恵がある人は非道徳的になるわけじゃないんだと
これはもう離れませんよと
ただ お釈迦様は私もこういうことを言ってますよと
人間に必要なのは道徳と知恵ですよと
他何にも要りませんよと
だから あのバラモン人の理性を生かして仏教の真理を教えてあげたんです
しかし 答えるのは相手なんです
まあそれからまあ道徳はいかなるものかと
あんたは完全な道徳を知っているのかと
それからお釈迦様は道徳はこのように完成するのよと
知恵はこのようにすれば完成しますよというところはちょっと足してあげたりする
相手が自分の知恵にいくらか足してくれたんだから
ものすごく喜んじゃうんですね
そういうことで お釈迦様と話した人は必ずもう仏教わかるということになるんですね
それでお釈迦様がこの押しつける
強引に押しつけるという態度をとらないで理性
だから理性が欲しいやと
なぜならば いつでも聞く人が自分で理解するんだから
そういうことで このすごくフラットで
上下関係なく 縦の関係なく
縦上から強引に命令で教えるということは仏教ではないんですね
だから理性っていうのは
あなたはどう思いますか？と言われたところで
自分の正直な答えなんです
これ正直な答え いろいろ左右して欲しくないんです
でも我々は世間で俗世間で生きている場合は
正直なことはどこまで正直か知らないんですね
結局は いつでも世間に合わせちゃうでしょ
だからこの 正直なところは大事にした方がね
その大事にしてから世間やことにちょっと合わせるとか
政治家の方々も本当に自分の気持ち別にあるんですよ
しかし 政治で政治という言葉もね
ポリティクスということもいかにごまかすかという意味ですから
英語で使う場合はね 政治学という意味じゃないんですよ
現代英語でポリティクスと言えばね
あの だからポリティカルリ correct というね
言葉までありますから
いかにアホなことでもポリティカル correct ということにもするんでしょうしね
例えば今 二酸化炭素を減らそうというと
まあ日本はみんなどうか分かりませんだけど
福田さんなんかは結構真剣なんですね
これは本当に問題であると
政治家としてというよりも
何か顔を見ると 本人がやっぱり地球のためにこれはどうしてもやらなくちゃいけないってなんとなく思っていたら
個人の気持ちですよ これ邪魔しているのは仏なんですね
どう見ても屁理屈ばっかり言っているんだから
だからあんたこれではダメよ
いいか言っちゃうと全部アウトでしょ
そこでいろいろ政治的に話を持っていくんです
政治的に話を持っていくといった時点で
正直なところは別やということ
ブッダも同じで 自分の家でトラブル起こるんですよ
アメリカ人が怠け者で新しい開発したくないし
改革したくないし 金持ちがもうこんなことやっちゃうと
もうもうちょっとお金がかかるんだよと
だからあの連中が 例えば億儲かってる人でも
5000万のちょっと下がってもすごく興奮するんですね
すごく病気なんですね
だから 例えば二酸化炭素を減らすことになってしまって
今まで 100億儲かったんですけど
二酸化炭素対策によって 100は 80になったと言ったってどうってことないでしょうね
まだ黒字が 80億ありますから
で アメリカではそこを認めないで
ほとんどユダヤ系でしょうし
だから今年 100億だから来年は 120億やと
それが正義やと思ってるでしょうね
そうなってくると 二酸化炭素を減らす話はもうもってのほかでも
話に話題にも持っていってはいけないということに
だからブッダさんが正直に言うならば
そんなことを断固反対だと言うべきなんです
科学的な証拠はないんだぞとか
いろんなことを言うべきなんですけど
本人もやっぱり政治的にこれまずいんだから
中国はのせいだと インドのせいだと
なんだらかんだら言うんです
だからこの政治世界では
この素直な気持ちと正直な気持ちと
世間に向けて言う話というのははっきりと 2つなんですね
私たち一般人になってくると
これごちゃになっちゃって
どこが正直かわからなくなってるんですね
だからこの正直なところ
このセクションの正直なところで
ここは外に出す自分という風に
ちゃんと建前と本音ですか
そこをはっきりしておくと
理性が生まれてくるんです
そこで本音のところは汚いんだから
これやっぱり何とかしましょうということになってくると
もう本当に本格的な理性が生まれてくるんです
すいません 3番なんですけども
ここでの意味はここでの意味は意味はですね
地理的に一切の場所にという意味とか
例えば五蘊の一切という
そういう意味にとったと思います
それはちょっと判断しかねませんね
注釈書はもう五蘊のことにしてますしね
一般の誰でも訳する場合は地理的なことを言って考えているんですね
もしかするとこのワジャンティではなくてチャランティとなった方が
チャラティっていうのは道徳的な生き方にもチャラティということを使いますからね
で サッバテウェサップリサチャランティニであった方が
もしかすると もう強運ということにもなり得るんですけどね
しかし ワジャンでもね
まあ牛によく使う単語だから縄張りっていうことでしょうしね
だから管轄というね 聖者の管轄はまあ強運になるんですね
まあそういうところはまあも仏教であるし
だからこの行はただ字義的にごく一般的な意味で理解していてもね
問題はないしね あまり判断はできませんね
逆に言えば お釈迦様のほとんどの教えはこの二つの解説はできます
俗世間に言う解説と真理の解説という涅槃解脱を示す解説と
で 俗世間にてみんな納得できる解説
いつでもその二つ二層なんですね
だから二層設定だったらこの二つも解説しなくちゃいけないので
二つも以上私はやっておきたいんです
どちらかにするかといってもね
一応まあ仏説はすべて解脱を推薦する教えであるということもあるし
お釈迦様の説法なら涅槃を示さない説法は説法じゃないんだと
もうおっしゃってるしね
それなら業にならなくちゃいけないんです
しかし 持ってきたエピソードはね
あまり字義的なんですね
とか いわゆる時空関係の話でね
まあ両方で取った方がいいんじゃないんですかね
はい  無明のことなんですが
触れて概念が生まれるまでの
そのちょっとの短い間にが無明ですか
あれ  こう グッていうか
触れて概念が生まれるまでのちょっと短いが無明ですか
どう説明すればいいんですかね
触れて概念が生まれる
でしょ  どうしてこういうことを言うかというと
無明っていうのは言葉のゆえだとか
そういうことをよくいろいろなところに書いてあるんですね
で 言葉 えっと 経論の本には生命であれば無明ですって書いてありましたので
言葉と無明っていうのは関係ないというふうになるわけなんですけど
そうであれば 目耳鼻舌身の無明であれば
言葉と無明は関係ない
ああ 関係 言葉っていうのはただの表記ですから
自分の経験 言葉っていうのはもともとね
仏教の定義はね 自分の経験っていうのは主観的な経験なんですね
主観的な経験には共通表記使って
そこは音にするか印にするか
文字にするか どちらでもいいんですね
それで言葉なんですね
だから言葉とは関係ないんですよ
言葉が生まれる前  前 前
前なんですね しかし 我々は言葉を使う時でも無明で使ってますけど
だからかなり誤解を起きたりするんですね
だからお釈迦様はいつでも対話するのはそういうわけなんです
一方的に喋ると 相手が自分勝手に判断するんですね
それでお釈迦様のやり方は
相手から言葉を聞くんです
あなたはどのように思いますか
とかね そこで相手の単語を使って
そこを整理しながら真理にするんです
そうすると誤解は生まれません
はいはい  お答えいただきありがとうございました
お釈迦様が再発見された真理というのは
ちょっと聞こえない  お釈迦様が
うん  再発見されたという真理は
うん  人間とそれ以外のすべての生命を
うん  幸福に導くものだと
考えるんですけれども
うん  翻ってですね 現在の世界の状況なんですが
狭い範囲で見ますと 南方上座部の国においてですけれども
スリランカでは内戦が起こっている
ミャンマーでは皆さんも記憶に新しいと思いますけれども
あのような 軍政というか
軍事政権が支配する それ以外のタイとかそういった南方の上座部を保持している国で
そういう風な争い事が起こっているということの現実というのは一体なぜなんでしょうか
それにはそれなりのいろいろ理由
原因あるんじゃないですかね
争いっていうのは全部間違い考え方から生まれるでしょうに
これも結局私は正しいということからね
争いが出てくるんだから
ブッダの教えを理解している人は争いには参加しませんしね
先ほど神の話が出た まあやっぱまあまあまあ私も神の存在はわからない
人間の勝手に作り出した妄想だというのが個人的な主張の観点なんですけれども
ですが 今の世界の情勢を見ますと
そういった幻想概念で自分たちで発展してきた神というものを信じている人間たちの方が割合としてははるかに多いですね
人口として でも実際 真理を用いて幸福になろうと叫んでいる仏教は少数派になってしまっている
けれども それはどういうわけでしょうか
それは力強い人に力弱い人は潰されるでしょうに
仏教はこのまま消滅するんでしょうか
仏教はこのまま消滅してしまうんでしょうか
潰れると思いますよ こんな能力のない世界でね
平気でヘリコプターは理屈やと言っている世界ではね
仏教はもう歯が立たないんですよ
だから理性ある人っていうのはものすごく稀なんです
稀でもあるんだから 仏教はなんとなくもうあれほど攻撃受けてるのに
あれほど仏教には 仏教が弾圧受けているのに
地球上から消えるっていうことはなかなかできないんですね
なぜならば もうもう一万人に
百万人に あるいは千万人に一人でも理性のある人がいるんですよ
だから理性があることっていうのはすごい力なんです
1万千万 1000万人の人々よりも一人一人の力があるんですね
だから理性っていうのはすごい力ですよ
だからこの少宗派の力っていうのはすごいものなんです
真理を握っているんだから
だから本当の力は智慧であるというね
ブッダの言葉ですから
大衆がたくさんいろんなことを言ったってもね
智慧の方が力ですよ で
昔ね スリランカではね
あるお坊さんがグナーナンダってお坊さんなんですけど
そんなに学者ではではなかったんです
口だけ達者でうるさいんですね
その人は我々イギリス植民地になっちゃって
仏教は法律的にも禁じられて
仕事は禁止 だからインドからタミル人を連れてきて
連れてきて 政府の仕事させたりして
みんなキリスト教にしたりして
で 問題いっぱい起こしちゃったんですけどね
しかし もう法律で禁止されている仏教は生き延びたんですけど
そこでそのお坊さんが一人で
あんた方は一方的に仏教を批判するんじゃなくて
堂々と話し合おうと で
堂々とキリスト教を公で批判することにしたんです
そうすると新聞にも載らなくちゃいけない
キリスト教に関係あるものだから
でないと仏教という言葉さえも
新聞でさえも出さないという
が もう邪教ということで
邪教の人 悪魔の教えを信じている人が仏教を馬鹿にしたら
キリスト教には黙っていられるわけじゃないでしょうね
だからそこは新聞で そこで一人のお坊さんがちゃんと討論して
もう世界に見せたんで
仏教ほどアホな宗教がないんだと
だから理性があれば 一人の力っていうのはもう
だから植民地でいるっていうことはどれほど弱いかというと
イギリス政府はどれほどものすごい力強くてね
今世界で一番大きいあれ作っちゃったんだから
今もイギリス グレートブリテンのそのキングダムほど大きい支配圏誰も作ってないでしょうに
それぐらい悪人といえば悪人なんですけど
だからその悪人に対しても
一人の人間が何のことなく立ち上がったんだから
言って もうキリスト教はもう致命的なダメージ受けたんです
それで もう我々自由になった
それ以後 それをその後なんですよ
仏教は自由になったのは
一応仏教徒は自由になったところから
また今のテロリスト行為とか
そこに対してね 我々お寺側
仏教の人々は自由に活動することはとにかくもうそれ嫌で
また教会の方に権力を与えるではないかということなんです
だから汚いテロ行為始めたんだから
知識的な争いだったら我々は答えますけど
これはもう人殺しですから
仏教は全然参加しない
何一つにも 今日の新聞でも何かこのどこかであの
北南からね コロンボまで来る一般人をたくさん乗せて
普通のバスなんですけど
森に隠れてバスにバーッと鉄砲で撃ってて
子供たちもいくらかこれ死にましたけどね
で逃げちゃったんだと
テロリストのグループは
何のことなく 何の武器も何も持ってない一般人を平気で殺だから簡単に殺せるしね
だからそれに逆襲しようとは全然誰も思わないんですね
だからまあ そういう蛮力よりは
まあ智慧の理性の方が力強いのです
だからスリランカ人もテロリストに対して理性で戦ってます
いつでも 理性で戦っていて
戦いは軍隊の仕事だから
一応軍隊は今やってますけどね
結構もう無茶苦茶負けていてね
負けて負けても逃げて逃げて
今なんかもうある あるテロリストが名乗って
私たちは戦いとかないんだぞとかね
そこは国際的にインターネットやら NBC やらアメリカのニュースは全部そこはニュース流すんですね
だから明確にこれは空振りだということでね
突然 だからずっと戦い始めた時からもう話し合いましょう
話し合いましょう 政府は一貫しているのに
例えば国際的にスリランカ政府がテロリストだと認定して合意にもらってる
アメリカやらイギリス
カナダ オーストラリアどこでもこの人はテロリストだと合意に認定してもらいますけど
他の国々に頼んで で スリランカ政府は LTT はテロリストだと認定しないんです
自分たちの問題なのに
法律で認定しません 口では言うんです
そこでシンガポールが怒って何だこれはと
私たちには LTT がテロリストだと認定しなさいという
あなた方は自分の国の問題でしょうにと
なんで認定していないんですか？と言ったら
あのね それで困りますよと
私たちは平和的に解決したいんだと
だから法律的でテロリストで違法だと認定した組織と対話できませんよと
だからまあいつでもいいんだから
平和的な解決のディスカッションテーブルに来るために
その窓口は開けているんだよと
それでも向こうにはどうしようもない
だからあなた方はそこら辺でいろいろこんなもうね
もうブラックマネーをね
麻薬 あれこれとかね もう武器売買とかね
そういうことは何とかしてくださいと
だからアメリカも参戦して
そこはもう昨日もね まあ 3人逮捕したんだよ
アメリカも 3年  3年  3年で武器売買をして
一人がインドネシアの人で
一人がパキスタンか マレーシアの人で
もう一人がスリランカのタミル人です
だから そういう国々はそれなりに法律的に
ちゃんと法律的な理性的にやっているしね
スリランカ政府はテロリスト組織としては認定しない
認定すると そこからもう潰さなくちゃいけないから
一方的に 一方的に潰そうとはしない
戦ってきたら攻撃する
先制攻撃はしません 今までしなかったんです
今はやってますけどね
とにかくもう爆弾落としちゃいます
うん まあだからやっぱり理性のほうが力強いんですよ
殴ったら殴り返すっていうことではね
問題は解決しません あのテロリストがね
もう私たちはもう停戦したいんだとかね
我々は停戦したいんだよと
我々は平和的な解決したいんだよと
これもまだスリランカ政府は知らない人間なんですね
で 言ったらもうそこから
催涙で流れるという で
また大騒ぎするでしょう
政府は一方的にこういう平和的な解決をしたいと思っているのにやってるんだよと
まあいろいろカラクリやってます
仏教に対する攻撃ですからね
だから仏教は教えですから
教えに対する攻撃は またかえって教えでやらなくちゃあかんでしょうに
なんで鉄砲持ってくるんですかね
まあ世の中ではね どこでも人間っていうのはね
まあ妄想やらね 吾輩は正しいという生き方ですから
世界は変っていうのは当たり前でしょうにね
それは私たちは気にもしません
知った上での活動なんです
しかし 問題は 私たちはこの世界に向けてたった一人で喋りますけど
一人で立ってもものすごい少数派で喋りますけど
大丈夫です 世界には反対的に何も言いませんだからね
だからただ単純に私は仏教だからということでは話は成り立ちません
勝手にしろよと ではなくて
よく理解して 世の中のことはこれこれこれ違うでしょうと
言える人の力はすごく強いんです
バチカンのホームページでね
仏教徒の腰抜けやと 慈しみに対してね
それはもうどんな生命に対したってもね
そんなことやって これでもうもうもうもうなんていうのか
とんでもない人間になるんだと
臆病者で腰抜けになるんだぞとかね
えらいことを言ってるつもりなんですけど
だから反対というと お前ら何言ってるのかと
愛って何やと 人殺すことやと聞きたいんですけど
分かってないんですよ
だから慈しみってこそが強い人間の態度やと
一端の派は気にしない
臆病者は気にして攻撃しようとするんです
だから誰とも戦わないことっていうのは腰抜けじゃなくて
あまりにも力ありすぎなんです
だから非道徳的なイモラル的な愛を教えているんですね
私は堂々とキリスト教の愛はイモラルであると
道徳じゃないんだと 堂々と言いますよ
ま 自信がある人はどうぞ当たってこいと
誰でもいいんです それはローマ法王本人であっても全然気にもしない
もしローマ法王が私に当たったら
結局は仏教徒になって終わります
その強さはどこにあるのかと
それはあり得ない話かもしれませんだけど
決して負けないという自信だけはあります
ですから この理性っていうのはすごい力なんです
だから 1万人が反対意見持ったっても
一人の人の方が勝ちます
正しくお互い対立したならば
世間は正しく対立はしないんですからね
いつでもまあやり方汚いんですから
そうするとこちらはまあいいやっていうことになるんです
例えば創価学会みたいな組織がね
じゃあ話し合いましょうと言って暴力団と一緒に来ると
もう それで私は怖くないんですけどね
もう私は脅されたことありますけど
あんた方はそんなにも腰抜けですかと
一言まで そんなにも怖いですかと
苦労してるの私は一人ですよ
結局何とも言えなくなっちゃいますね
まあそういうことで ミャンマー軍隊とか
いろいろみんな自分の個人的なもう汚い考え方でしょうね
ミャンマーの政府にしてもね
軍隊がもう絶対誰にもこの権力をあげませんということで
国の財産全部一人占めにして
軍人でなきゃ仕事は禁止とかね
政治活動は一切禁止とかね
選挙があっても出て出られませんよと
軍人でなければとかね
それっていうのはもう仏教の人だけらもないでしょう
それはどうするのかということは
私たちには関係ないんです
即世間はどうするべきかということは関係ない
勝手にしろ はい 他の質問がなければ
ここら辺で終了したいと思いますけど
はい  はいはい  すみません
理性はデータを見て判断するのが理性であるということで
難しいことはちょっと私
今の話だとわからないんだけど
自分の理性を五戒の文とそれと今ね
慈悲の瞑想と慈経 その辺りを読むことで自分の理性を育て
育てようと思っている
そのお供えを始めているわけですけど
それでよろしいでしょうか
まああの理性は慈しみでも現れます
だから慈しみに対する理性っていうのはたった一行なんです
すべての生命は幸福になりたい
というのは生命の切望ですね
希望ですね それは一切の生命に共通していると
それは真理のポイント
そこから慈悲の瞑想するなりに
慈悲を上げるなりに慈悲を実践するんです
私は腰抜けじゃないんだよと
ただ事実言ってるだけだと
私は怯えて あなたも幸福であります
あなたも幸福でありますよと
そんなことじゃないんだよと
誰であろうとも幸福になりたいと思ってるんではないかと
何か間違いありますかと
要するに強気なんですね
そういうわけで 慈しみの実践でも理性はすごくしっかりと成長します
では終了しましょうか
じゃあ回向の文で終了したいと思います
回向の文 仏法僧の三宝に礼拝敬し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この書によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして癒すが得られますように
どうもありがとうございます